Fritz Hopper made food from the air he
invented a process that takes nitrogen
from the air and turns it into
fertilizer this revolutionized
Agriculture and fed billions of people
who otherwise might have starved he
became a hero in his native Germany and
won a Nobel Prize yet the man who fed
billions also had a hand in unspeakable
atrocities fritzhabber developed poison
gas which was then used by both sides in
World War One his work led to the
development of the devastating use of
gas during the Holocaust Haber himself
was born to a Jewish Family in 1868 in
Breslow a city that was then part of
Germany but is now located in Poland and
is known as viratswave he grew up
without his mother who died weeks after
giving birth Fritz's father Zig freed
was devastated he threw himself into his
business and became a prosperous dye
Merchant Siegfried eventually remarried
and had three daughters he doted on his
girls but not on Fritz who was a
reminder of the pain of losing his first
wife after Fritz graduated from an elite
school and celebrated with friends in a
pub till the wee hours of the morning
his dad was not happy when he overslept
and skipped family breakfast Fritz's
father took his three girls to Fritz's
bedroom and said look well this is how
the life of a drunkard begins that
deeply hurt his son
Fritz wanted out of his father's house
and out of Breslau he wanted to break
free of the chains that wear me down as
he wrote to a friend
he decided to go to university to study
chemistry he had already been conducting
homemade experiments at his aunt's house
he studied at several German
universities and earned a doctorate
inorganic chemistry in 1891. Haber also
served a year in the military and hoped
to be commissioned as an officer in the
reserves but he likely understood that
he was rejected because of his Jewish
Heritage he later converted to
Christianity possibly to advance his
career or to assimilate in German
Society where anti-Semitism was Rising
rejection became part of his life when
he applied to join the lab of the
esteemed physical chemist Wilhelm Oswald
and Leipzig his application was denied
while that of his friend and fella
student Richard abeg was accepted no one
appeared to recognize his Brilliance he
moved from job to job working at
factories in Eastern Europe through his
dad's connections finally in 1894 at the
age of 26 he was hired as an assistant
at the Technical University of carlsruhe
Now The carlsrua Institute of Technology
in the department of chemical and fuel
technology the university wasn't
renowned at the time but this worked in
his favor as the supervisors gave him
the freedom to pursue his own ideas when
someone asked how he managed to master a
range of Specialties in chemistry so
quickly Haba replied that he studied
every night until 2AM until I got it
sometimes he'd Escape into sanatoriums
to calm his nerves he worked so hard
that his wife chemist Clara emervar
wrote Fritz is so scattered if I didn't
bring him to his son every once in a
while he wouldn't even know that he was
a father Clara was also the child of a
prosperous Merchant she was also born to
a Jewish Family and later converted to
Christianity
because she couldn't obtain good
schooling at a young age due to her
gender she made up for it with private
tutors At first she was only allowed to
attend University as a guest as women
were not legally admissible at the time
when that policy changed she became the
first woman in Germany to earn a PhD in
chemistry yet her career was
overshadowed by her husbands she
couldn't advance in Academia as she was
expected to fulfill the role of the
professor's wife
hubber was working at the University
when a British scientist issued a dire
warning in 1898
Sir William Crooks declared that England
in all civilized Nations stand in deadly
Peril of not having enough to eat he
focused his concern on the bread Eaters
of the whole world the quote great
Caucasian race he predicted that the
world would face famine within decades
unless a new source of nitrogen for
agricultural fertilizers could be found
nitrogen is a vital nutrient for plant
growth scientists relied on limited
natural sources of nitrogen to fertilize
soil such as animal manure burden bat
droppings or sodium nitrate from Chilean
mines but these resources are limited
nitrogen is abundant in the atmosphere
78 of the air is made up of nitrogen
however in the way that humans can't
drink salt water plants can't use
nitrogen directly from the air as a
source of nutrition because of its
strong triple bond that makes it
difficult for plants to digest it must
be converted into a more useful form
Hopper discovered that hydrogen breaks
the strong triple bond of nitrogen and
converts it to ammonia or NH3 which is
easier for plants to absorb and use
ammonia is the raw material for common
nitrogen-based fertilizers providing
plants with essential nutrients for
growth increasing crop yields and food
production Hopper actually struggled at
first to find the point at which
hydrogen and nitrogen atoms can bind
into ammonia he almost gave up until a
rival scientist insulted him Walter
Ernst said it is unfortunate that so
little ammonia is formed in this state
of equilibrium compared with what habers
highly inaccurate numbers led us to
assume okay that really ticked topper
off Andy became obsessed with obtaining
ammonia before nerds did Hopper tried
using extreme heat to encourage the
formation of ammonia but that didn't
work even 1000 degrees Celsius only
produced a minuscule amount of ammonia
one hundredth of one percent then he
thought what about extreme heat combined
with extreme pressure hubber found an
ally in Germany's largest Chemical
Company BASF which gave him a generous
salary to pay for lab equipment and
higher assistance in March 1909 he
achieved a breakthrough
Haber used a catalyst osmia to
accelerate the chemical reaction between
nitrogen and hydrogen they combine to
produce ammonia with a yield of around
six percent Haber had discovered a
process akin to Turning lead into gold
it would make him fabulously rich
BASF agreed to pay him 1.5 fennig the
German scent in royalties for each kilo
of ammonia produced which added up to a
significant sum as the large-scale
production of ammonia followed a chemist
and engineer at BASF Carl Bosch was
responsible for scaling up and
commercializing the production of
ammonia the process of synthesizing
ammonia is known worldwide as the hobber
Bosch process
today an estimated 150 million metric
tons of nitrogen is extracted from the
air annually transformed into ammonia
and distributed as nourishing fertilizer
for crops there are long-term
environmental concerns to consider
chemicals from these fertilizers can
find their way into water systems
harming water quality and the
surrounding ecosystems but without the
hobber Bosch process it's likely that
billions of people would not have been
able to obtain the food and nutrition
they need to survive about half of our
planet's seven billion people are fed
with crops grown using synthetic
fertilizers
in 1911 two years after his
groundbreaking discovery Hopper became
the founding director of a prestigious
new research institution the Kaiser
Wilhelm Institute for physical chemistry
and electrochemistry
this photo shows Haber at the opening
ceremony steps behind the German Emperor
and King of Prussia who lent his name to
The Institute Haber was now a member of
the nation's Elite and Germany was a
nation that had great ambition
Haber was determined to support his
country in World War One unlike Albert
Einstein who was horrified that his
fellow scientists use their skills to
help Germany's war effort Einstein the
pacifist put it this way our entire much
praised technological progress and
civilization generally could be compared
to an ax in the hand of a pathological
Criminal
hubbers process for synthesizing ammonia
also enabled the creation of explosives
synthesized ammonia can be converted
into nitric acid which can be used to
create nitrates essential components in
powerful explosives because of habra's
process Germany could fight on despite
British warships blocking nitrate
supplies from South America but
explosives would not be haber's greatest
contribution to his country's war effort
Hopper suggested to German military
leaders that they use chlorine gas as a
weapon German High command was willing
to try anything to break the stalemate
on the Western Front on April 22 1915
German troops stationed in Belgium
released 5000 tanks containing chlorine
gas which drifted across the battlefield
to Allied positions a British officer
described the horror of seeing French
Colonial Soldiers with gray faces and
protruding eyeballs clutching their
throats and choking as they ran many of
them dropping in their tracks and lying
on the sodden Earth with limbs convulse
and features distorted in death
soldiers panicked and abandoned their
positions creating a Four Mile Gap in
the front line that the Germans failed
to exploit several German commanders had
actually opposed using poison gas on the
battlefield they thought it was a
dishonorable and inhumane way to fight
as traditionally soldiers faced each
other directly in battle yet Hopper
didn't consider poison gas any worse
than bullets he argued innumerable human
lives would be saved if the war could be
ended more quickly this way
unfortunately it didn't speed up the war
gas was heavily dependent on the way the
wind blew and the Allies later used the
same weapon themselves
Haber was promoted to the rank of
Captain in recognition of his efforts in
developing chemical warfare it clearly
went to his head the first president of
Israel quoted him as saying I was one of
the mightiest men in Germany I was more
than a great Army Commander more than a
captain of industry I was the founder of
Industries all doors were open to me
on April 1st 1915 Haber returned to
Berlin to celebrate his promotion that
same night his wife shot herself with
his army pistol in their Garden their
12-year-old son Herman found his dying
mother
there's been much speculation about why
Clara ended her own life decades later
cousin Paul crassa wrote she was in
despair over the horrible consequences
of gas Warfare for which she'd seen the
preparations along with the tests on
animals
Clara had been miserable for a long time
she struggled with the gender roles
expected ever leaving her own Ambitions
to Fall by the wayside she detailed her
suffering in a letter to her Mentor
Richard abeck who had introduced her to
her husband what Fritz has gained during
these last eight years I have lost and
what's left of me fills me with the
deepest dissatisfaction
Hopper never defended against public
speculation that it was his work that
caused his wife's death we got a glimpse
of his emotional state when he wrote to
his former Mentor chemist Carl Engler
six weeks later
for a month I doubted that I could keep
going but now the war with its Dreadful
images and constant demands in all my
Powers has made me calmer
a day after Clara took her own life
Haber returned to the front lines he
then supervised the development of an
even more horrific weapon mustard gas
unlike chlorine gas mustard gas didn't
blow away with the wind and instead
stuck to close causing painful blisters
and blinding soldiers who got it in
their eyes Hopper called it a fabulous
success
by the end of the war an estimated 90
000 soldiers had been killed by poison
gas and more than a million suffered
injuries despite Harbor's efforts
Germany lost the war the effectiveness
of gas diminished as the Allies started
using the same weapon it didn't help
that Germany made a major strategic
blunder when it began to attack both
military and civilian ships without
distinguishing between the two which
brought the U.S into the war and tilted
the balance of power after Germany
surrendered Hopper worried that he'd be
tried as a war criminal he moved with
his son his second wife Charlotte and
their young daughter to neutral
Switzerland for a time and even grew a
beard as a disguise
however instead of being prosecuted for
war crimes Haber was honored with a
Nobel Prize in chemistry in 1919. the
Nobel Prize committee declared his
synthesis of ammonia the greatest
benefit to mankind
but the award was controversial because
of haber's development of chemical
weapons
two French scientists who had been
offered prizes turned them down in
protest although he won the Nobel Prize
his legacy is forever tarnished Hopper
failed to realize that his Nation would
use his chemical weapon against innocent
civilians the irony is that his own
people the Jewish people would become
the primary victims the Nazis used
zyclon B to exterminate over a million
people in concentration camps in World
War II scientists at Harbor's Institute
had developed an earlier version of
zyclon to get rid of insect infestations
in flower mills and granaries then they
introduced another version of the
pesticide that was easier to handle and
more powerful without imagining it would
ever be used on people
haber's own extended family perished in
Hitler's gas Chambers
anti-Semitism grew after the first world
war as some Germans felt the Jewish
people were responsible for the
country's problems Hitler's Nazi party
capitalized on the widespread
unemployment poverty and unrest to fuel
its rise to power despite his
contributions to his beloved Germany
Harbor realized he would soon become a
target of Nazi repression his conversion
to Christianity was irrelevant it was
his ancestry that mattered he was forced
to fire some Jewish scientists at his
government-funded research institute and
a few days later Haber resigned his own
position in protest in his resignation
letter to the Prussian minister of
culture Hopper emphasized his lifelong
principle my tradition requires that
when choosing co-workers for a
scientific post I consider only the
professional and personal
characteristics of the applicant without
regard for their racial makeup
scientist Max Planck tried to save
Harbor's institution Planck appealed
directly to Hitler trying to convince
him that forcing valuable Jews to leave
would hurt Germany Hitler apparently
flew into a rage Nazi policy left no
room for exceptions not even for the man
who had arguably contributed more to
Germany's might during World War One
than anyone else
Einstein who had been traveling when the
Nazis came to power and declared he
wouldn't return to Germany put it this
way in a letter to Haber I can imagine
your inner conflicts it is somewhat like
having to abandon a theory on which you
have worked your whole life it's not the
same for me as I never believed in it in
the least Einstein put it more
delicately in a letter to haber's son
after Hopper's death it was the tragedy
of the German Jew the tragedy of
unrequited love
Hopper tried his entire life to be the
perfect German despite his religious
conversion despite one of the greatest
scientific discoveries of all time
despite his attempt to save his country
the only thing that mattered in the end
was that he was Jewish he summed up his
feelings in a letter to the prominent
German chemist Richard vilstadter I am
bitter as never before in the feeling
that this is unbearable increases by the
day
as if it couldn't be worse Hopper found
himself in a dire financial situation
hyperinflation after World War one had
diminished the value of his royalties
from his ammonia patents he also had to
financially support his second wife
after their divorce the global financial
crisis of 1929 ate away what was left of
his finances he desperately searched for
a way out of his precarious situation a
former foe actually came to his rescue
British chemist William Pope who worked
on the development of gas Warfare for
the British and offered Haber a
temporary position at the University of
Cambridge but by then haber's Health had
worsened he eventually left England to
seek treatment at a sanatorium in
Switzerland he got as far as Basel when
his heart failed on the night of January
29 1934 Fritz Harbor died
he was 65 years old
Haber had requested to his son Herman
that this be written on his gravestone
in War and Peace as long as it was
granted him a servant of his homeland
Herman refused his father's wishes he
also refused to attend his father's
memorial service believing he couldn't
be honored in the country that had
rejected him scientist Max Planck
courageously organized a service in
Berlin on the one-year anniversary of
haber's death despite intimidation by
the Nazis who ordered state employees to
stay away many of the scientists wives
bravely attended the great industrialist
Carl Bosch was also there he owed his
career to Haber the hobber Bosch process
led to the stunning growth of Bosch's
company BASF which later merged with
other chemical companies to form the
conglomerate IG farbin which the
Americans seized after World War II
although Hubbard tried to distance
himself from his Jewish Heritage nearly
his whole life in his final days he
seemed to have a change of heart he
struck up a friendship with a Zionist
kaim Wiseman who fought to establish the
state of Israel Haber lamented to
Wiseman I was one of the mightiest men
in Germany at the end of my life I find
myself a bankrupt when I am gone and
forgotten your work will stand a shining
monument in the long history of our
people
despite his significant contribution to
the field of chemistry there is no
statue of Fritz Harbor in Germany or
anywhere the only place that bears his
name is the Institute he once LED the
Kaiser Wilhelm Institute was renamed the
fritzhaber Institute of the Max Planck
Society in 1953. one of the institute's
directors explained that the name is a
reminder that science can be used as a
tool for good and also as a tool for
evil
despite the controversy surrounding
fritzhabber his contributions to science
have left a lasting impact on the world
if you'd like to develop your skills in
science I highly recommend brilliant.org
a website and app where you can brush up
on your stem skills my viewers enjoy
brilliant scientific thinking course
where you can solve puzzles
interactively and build up the skills
for making breakthroughs in any
scientific field
brilliant offers courses in a wide range
of stem subjects including computer
science data science and math
their content is structured in a way
where you can dive deeper into advanced
topics as you progress giving you an
edge in your career I personally use
brilliant to help boost my critical
thinking skills through their logic
puzzles
if you ever get stuck you can view the
explanation to see where you went wrong
brilliant is free to try out for 30 days
if you head to the custom link in my
description
brilliant.org newsthink in the first 200
people who sign up using my link will
get 20 off Brilliance premium
subscription which gives you access to
their thousands of offerings
thanks for watching I'm Cindy Palm